hello I'm gav I'm Dan we're The Slow Mo
Guys bit dark in it yeah it's not our
usual time for filming no it's not very
easy to film slo-mo at night unless your
subject is very bright
it's an unintentional rhyme but this is
a very highly requested video and I have
a sort of slightly bent cricket bat yeah
I have some uh some sort of nails made
of
we're going to British it up with the
cricket bat and uh this is going to make
a lot of Sparks so we're going to melt
that down into a liquid glob and I'm
going to attempt to
knock it for six pretty much right I
should point out that um we're on a lens
that is f 0.95 wow and the ISO on this
camera is the 32 000. I might just do a
little demo of what I can actually see
with my eyes hold on this is what I can
see
but thankfully with technology
you can oh are you doing that the whole
time
using the 4K phantom for my wide I'm at
a thousand frames a second and over here
Phantom t4040 my type I'm at 10 000
frames a second
so you're putting in some Nails putting
some nails and this is an electric
furnace yeah it's an induction Furniture
how many watts does this Ninja 3 500
watts three and a half kilowatts very
distracted by I think what is planes in
the sky behind you or stars or
someone's twinkling UFOs probably
we'll turn it on
but yeah is that like the the uh the
number readout
that's the number without yeah I've
never seen someone lit up by a seven
segment display before
look at see these green Sparks yeah it's
like it's like a sparkler in it yeah so
this is what we'll expect to see when we
give it a right good whack all right
good work
okay it's gonna be three two one throw
okay yeah
you look pretty sick right now I look
sick right now yeah you look cool like
look at you
I think the hardest part of this is
going to be triggering the camera I
would agree thankfully I don't
have to might have to just stand on it
like pin it under my foot you have all
the hard Parts here actually
I think we're ready okay
are you ready
yeah right it's gonna be three two one
throw okay okay three two one throw
nice one
oh I think you nailed that whoa I think
you nailed it that was quick that was
quick wouldn't it wow
did you get it got it nice bee that was
a quality hit flipping glad it's nice
cause I'm wearing this and it's so hot
is that just oh it's me I've loved it
there yeah so I was wide on this one
um didn't know exposure or Focus so
we'll see we'll see what happens I I set
the focus before the sun went all the
way down
that's already cool
yeah it's just so bright it looks yellow
though not white that's nice yeah it's
really cool I'll see what happens here
though because I haven't connected with
anything yet so some hits the floor
imagine first yeah it's flashing on the
floor especially on the floor
that's great
that's Mickey
oops it's possible even though you were
wide you look there's still stuff going
out of frame yeah you can barely see us
now we're just in there oh this is going
to be a compression nightmare oh no I
want to put this up in 8k or something
do you know what's awesome as well you
you hit like the top glass even though
you only hit like a little bit of it
still and
like what other materials would you be
able to hit with a cricket bat and it
explode that much I know which without
being explosive I would say pretty happy
with the exposure that was also
um not a defensive shot in cricket that
was definitely you know you were trying
to hit the phone that was basically
baseball yeah
now let's go and look at the t4040s 10
000 frame a second shot lovely to my eye
it looked like a solid stream here we go
the swings the upswing's coming
I can see her I really like that some of
it hit the floor to light my to light
the swing
look at that
oh
looks like the sun that's pretty intense
look at the amount of individual things
happening there's more Sparks than
pixels in the sensor this will not work
on YouTube
man that's so annoying this is just one
of those things that's just really hard
to get across I know just like a massive
firework pretty much it was just like we
created our own firework with a cricket
bat
I didn't did you feel anything I didn't
feel a thing not a thing no I I could
just suddenly see a lot yeah it was like
it was like someone turned a massive
light on I think if I did it different
I'd go much closer on that one and much
wider on this one
okay
I'm Freddie flintoff
ready
three two one
oh God
well that was chaos what happened there
I you twyed I I didn't like get out the
way enough oh sorry you and annihilated
the uh The Crucible I was too Keen yeah
it's all right it's all right but we
definitely can't do it again now
hahaha
thank you
whoa you're so white I love that that's
that's a cool reveal yeah isn't it I
couldn't tell then Bang
[Music]
yeah you got like the end drags
and you annihilated The Crucible that I
was holding as well
it's my fault for not getting out there
a bit more
I think I stood a bit too close to you
okay that's some fine particles there
too fine look how much hit you in the
face
wow so much of it just went straight in
your
grid
no you didn't feel any of that nothing I
can't even see what's going on to be
honest there's just so much
I like the barely Shadows here yeah
cool look
a brief Interruption now for the sponsor
of this video Henson shaving it's
basically a high quality razor with a
single disposable razor blade on the top
and what I like about this company is
that they don't seem to use any plastic
even in the packaging materials and
there's no subscription model so there's
no recurring costs you can actually buy
a hundred disposable razor blades in a
box this size and that lasts about five
years worth of Shaving if you use the
code slow-mo guys you get this 100 pack
for free get 20 of those you're good for
a century as a company that also has
involvement making Aerospace Parts a lot
of focus is put into the Precision of
the Machining process of the razor
itself the Disposable blade is very thin
and sits between two pieces of metal and
the razor actually only sticks out by
about a third of a millimeter this
combination of the tiny blade exposure
plus the elimination of flex means it's
very smooth and safe razor to use and
I've been enjoying it if you're a
regular trimmer I think you'll like this
razor make sure you check out the link
in the description below use the code
slow-mo guys in the checkout and big
thanks to Henson shaving for sponsoring
the channel
back to the darkness
glorious
and I reckon didn't get a six but I at
least got a four I reckon that was
boundary for sure definitely yeah
definitely hit the Rope there straight
in the Rope straight in the Rope bounced
up hit a baby in the head in all
seriously snow you did you did really
well I'm just gonna I I was shocked that
I actually connected with it and the bat
has survived just fine aside from this
part where I absolutely mullered The
Crucible it's funny that yeah oh yeah
God I thought there'd be some Char marks
or something but yeah not at all yeah
there you go hopefully you enjoyed that
video uh we accidentally destroyed the
YouTube algorithm for compression again
but uh that can happen in this line of
work well you do have the raw file so
maybe in like 50 years yep everyone else
will be able to see exactly what it's
supposed to look like definitely in the
meantime just you and you and I will
have a look but we do have other videos
that you can watch you know some that
are visible Destroy YouTube
make sure you subscribe if you like
slow-mo and here's a video that you can
see
you next time bye bye
should we go to bed can we just leave
all this here yeah I wish